da kommt ein riesiges schwert
v
liebe freunde willkommen zu einer neuen
folge
ich habe mir keine gedanken gemacht wie
metro jetzt fange ich einfach mal an ich
werde übrigens bald auch ein album
rausbringen weil ich finde ich kann
ukulele so gut spielen und das wird so
tolle musik werden ihm ist es alle
kaufen
nein einfach nein ja freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft commands tut mir leid dass die
jetzt heute am sonntag kommt ich bin
nämlich alles so ein bisschen chaotisch
gerade ich hatte ja max besucht habt ja
dem video gesehen und dann war alles
ganz spontan und dann konnte ich sitze
nicht mehr aufnehmen jedenfalls habe ich
mir gedacht bevor diese woche daten gar
keine folge kommen mache ich einfach
dann heute am sonntag eine und ich hatte
mir was neues überlegen uns warten viele
in die kommentare der letzten folge
geschrieben ja luca macht doch einfach
so dass du dich nicht auf irgendwelche
tage fokussiert sondern einfach dann
hoch wenn du bock hast wenn du geile
einsendungen hast und das habe ich mir
doch vorgenommen also es wird
wahrscheinlich wieder jeden freitag was
kommen wo ich euch zu 3,1 vorstelle
einfach nur weil bei 5,2 die folgen
echten immer ein bisschen zu lang mit
dem bearbeiten dass ich teilweise in der
letzten folge echt drei stunden nur um
das video zu bearbeiten ohne vorher
commands raussuchen und testet und alles
mögliche allerdings apropos einsendungen
dass google antworten formular ist voll
mit 50.000 antworten und ich kann darauf
nicht mehr zugreifen weil zu
verantworten da sind da habe ich jetzt
auch an google schon was geschrieben
ohne fehlermeldungen da kann man daher
so draufklicken also ich hoffe dass wir
das sich da alles besser
sonst würde ich euch einfach bitten wenn
irgendein coolen command kennt oder
jemanden der einen coolen com hat in
einem video gebaut hat oder so einfach
und in die kommentaren link dazu posten
geht er jetzt auch bei youtube und sonst
würd ich sagen fangen jetzt auch endlich
angekommen
einzig wirklich freuen wenn wir zum ende
dran bleibt und wir haben wieder ein
paar meisten sachen dabei also auf jeden
fall jetzt nicht auf youporn gehen und
wir drücken natürlich erstmal gfp
command unterstrich blog damit wir den
command blog bekommen und wir holen uns
auch einen hebel um das ganze ding zu
betätigen und dann geben wir diesen
befehl 21 schon skala brian und am
anfang jetzt hier so ein paar effekte
einfach dieses ding hat dieses monster
und wird am anfang sah man zombie der
daneben gesponnen wird also drücke ich
einfach mal hier drauf und wir sehen
schon dort wird ein hero 3 kombi des
sports war es einfach ein ganz normaler
zombie mit schwert in der hand mit ein
paar
extra eigenschaften der blog so ein
bisschen ich weiß nicht ob man das
irgendwann jetzt gleich mal sehen kann
das tempo wird kommen schon bruder
blogger mal ein wenig blo blo blo blo
blo blo
da hat der ganze globus und der heißt
hat einfach lieber freund weil der
sonntag ding hat und hat einfach einen
freien kopf auf also von neil o'brien
monster einfach ist quasi einfach ein
zombie mit dem kopf verbraucht und zwar
ist dieser command von einem spanischen
youtuber namens kellerkinder ich meine
kinder kriegt also so wird es für
zugesendet ihr findet links dazu in der
beschreibung also wie er den command
gemacht hat der just case dingsbums also
diese pace bin sache damit ihr den
command selber testen könnt was hat denn
jetzt eigentlich hin
naja mein kleiner harmonie und da sind
halt auch noch ein paar mehr commands
drin also beispielsweise das ist hier
ein cabrio glaube ich das pferd oder
irgendwie so hieber bleiben auf einem
pferd da kann ich bin zurzeit noch an
spanisch lernen ich kann es noch nicht
so toll hier soll da haben wir
beispielsweise tv bringt auch noch auf
einem pferd dann gibt es auch noch
lieber bryan mit 1 im silberfisch meine
ich das findet ihr alles in der
beschreibung das muss ich glaube ich
jetzt nicht alles einzeln vorstellen
das war auf jeden fall kommen nummer
eins einfach was sind simpel ist einfach
so sondern in einen zombie hier einmal
mit einem heber breitkopf und ein
schwert und ein paar effekten und teilte
brand verstehen und hält hier
beispielsweise noch auf dem zombie fährt
mit rüstung alle möglichen sind ein paar
verschiedene auswahlmöglichkeiten
umbreit ins game reinzukriegen kann man
bestimmt den einen oder anderen
mitspieler auf dem server mit trollen
und das war wie man direkt bei damit
command nummer freunde was wäre diese
command serie ohne einkommen von
minecraft übrigens noch mal alles gut
werden dass hier siehst er hat glaube
ich vor gestern oder vorgestern oder
weiß ich nicht genau wenn ihr die folge
sehen weil ich wieder voll produzieren
weil ich wieder unterwegs bin hat er die
33 1333 abonnenten erreicht also geht
doch mal bitte alle auf seinem kanal ist
eine beschreibung verlinkt und
gratuliert ihm dazu und stelle ich hier
jetzt mal eben meinen command block hin
und dass wir uns war habe ich euch ja
letztens schon mal das ist wieder ein
sehr sehr langer kommen warum kennt man
ihn auch sonst habe ich euch ja letztens
schon mal seht schon hier wieder drin
das ist der ganze command das ist auf
jeden fall sehr sehr heiß und das ist
immer der ganze command er hat ja
letztens schon mal den ok was als
letztes aber ich hatte ja letztens einen
roger command wann allerdings
vorgestellt und jetzt gibt es einen mord
furniture command also ich drücke
einfach mal den schalter ihr seht schon
dort etwas riesiges kreiert wieder diese
maschine wo man dann nachher einfach
draufklicken kann und zwar seht ihr
schon ich habe zurzeit so ein paar bugs
das liegt nicht am shader das habe ich
mit allen trainern und es liegt nicht am
text beck gerade ohne technische beck
spiele max hat das ganze auch ich weiß
jetzt dass noch mehr von euch haben ja
ich glaube dass eine erklären vielleicht
muss ich auch minecraft x update oder so
ich spiele immer noch auf der 1.8 normal
also nicht einfach um 3 oder so aber
keine ahnung worden das liegt vielleicht
kann mir das jemand von euch sagen ich
weiß es nicht wir klicken auf jeden fall
erstmal offen gerteis und ihr seht schon
unser inventar wird ersetzt durch diese
vier items wir haben hier einmal ein
sofa zum hinsetzen eine lampe die licht
macht dann haben wir hier noch ein ganz
normales reiter waßmann auf den boden
legen kann und dass die dies trading und
zwar in seinem video das ganze schon
super toll erklärt also auf jeden fall
da auch mal vorbei schauen wie er das
ganze erklärt weil er sich echt immer
extrem viel mühe gibt er redet ja nicht
in diesem command vorstellung des videos
sondern schreibt das ganze in englisch
darüber das ist sehr cool gemacht und
zwar nicht erst mal diese drei sache
damit nämlich das sofa hier haben wir
die lampe und hier haben wir ein wow
legt sich einfach auf das gastro das
ganze natürlich wieder mit diesen sweet
spot eiern also item lamb und so ver
werden diesmal hinzugefügt vorher waren
es ja glaube ich fernseher table jbl
pile of books und so was alles also ein
paar mehr sachen das ist allerdings auch
nur das motto der mörfelder command okay
was heißt nur naja egal ich kann hier
erstmal in den game mode drei gehen
damit ihr seht woraus das ganze gemacht
ist wieder hauptsächlich ausrüstung
ständern hier beispielsweise rüstung
ständer der einfachsten altem in der
hand hat und so ich denke das kann man
sich alles von selbst erklären dann
gehen wir wieder den game ott 1 und zwar
kann ich mich jetzt hier auf jede
beliebige position des der bank
draufsetzen übrigens das dass ich kein
skin habe liegt daran dass ich euch
morgen die modifikation vorstelle woran
das weswegen das ist blabla und wenn ich
hier dementsprechend dann wieder
schiffbrücke kann ich da wieder
runtergehen dann kann ich mich auch mal
hierhin setzen beispielsweise und
natürlich auch in die mit in die mitte
ab in der er sich in der mitte für eine
scheiße man ebenfalls kann man das ganze
auch deaktivieren indem ich einfach mit
denen die streiten da einmal drunter
clique dann seht ihr schon kommt so
komische sounds und so ein komisches
feuerwerk dingsbums und wenn ich jetzt
mal richtig drauf machen geht es nicht
also ich
da jetzt nicht irgendwie mich hinsetzen
oder so allerdings wenn ich das ganze
zerstören will
habt ihr es gerade schon gesehen muss
ich einfach mit dem die streiten dadurch
laufen dann geht das ganze weg dann
dieses licht muss ich glaube ich nicht
viel zu sagen wenn ich auch mal hier
teilt 20.000 machte werde auch schon das
ganze macht auch ein bisschen licht ist
ja es gemacht und jetzt diese alte sich
lassen einfach so dunkel werde jetzt
nicht mit den lampen hier
das ist ganz neues also sind sieht ein
bisschen so hab ich auf einmal redstone
ich hab's ausgetauscht gegen das altern
hier
das ist zwar ein kleiner fehler
meinerseits jetzt gewesen allerdings
wollte ich euch das auch noch zeigen und
zwar kann man einfach den das item was
hier liegt austauschen und zwar ist es
ja ganz einfach eine rüstung ständer der
item in der hand hat das heißt ich kann
ein beliebiges item nehmen
beispielsweise sogar dieses teams ich
bin gegen gelaufen
diese mohn und kann damit jetzt
beispielsweise wenn ich an altem hinlege
ich brauche wieder so ein beispielsweise
counter kann man jemand zählen wir auf
die in diesem video beispielsweise sagen
das ist unfassbar viel ich kann jetzt
nämlich diesem diesem diese rose einfach
mal dahin legen da hinlegen dann so
machen beispielsweise dem blog bei
blöcken sieht komisch aus und wenn ich
ein schwert beispielsweise hinlege sieht
auch extrem komisch aus also jetzt schon
da
das ist halt einfach eine rüstung
ständer der das ganze halt in der hand
hält und es steht erhalt wir waren ja
wünschen im game mode 3 kurz r steht da
halt und hat sie nach hand deswegen ist
das schwert halt nicht so von oben nach
unten sondern liegt er so in länglichen
ja das war auf jeden fall jetzt command
nummer zwei von al chaima kreft auf
jeden fall mal vorbeischauen
ihm gratulieren erscheinen spitzen typ
und ja mit eingestreuten dann einfach
wieder hiergegen laufen dann haben wir
die ganzen sachen hier wieder kaputt
auch ich hier einfach gegen laufen dann
ist es auch wieder weg der rüstung
ständer dass eltern dementsprechend halt
auch das war auf jeden fall kommt nummer
zwei ich glaube ich rede viel zu viel
wir machen weiter mit freunden falls ich
müde aussehe ich habe die letzte nacht
vier stunden geschlafen die da nur ich
möchte euch das immer nicht vor heulen
aber viele sagen du siehst du aus als
hättest du gekifft oder so freunde es
ist neun uhr als ob ich irgendwie kiffen
sollte und vor allem um blöd naja egal
weil ich so lange an die video von
gestern geschnitten hatte das hat mir
aber einfach mega viel spaß gemacht das
video zu schneiden weil es einfach mega
witzig war die
das zu zweit an einem pc mit max also
das kann man gestern auf meinem
charakter nicht gewinner unbedingt
checken meine lieben lucanet ag tri tra
wo alles favorisiert alles leid mein
gott ich zeige euch jetzt aber erstmal
den command nummer 3 und zwar da wir
vorhin schon bei den items waren die man
auf den boden legen konnte und verändern
konnte ist kummer nummer drei auch etwas
mit items und zwar das hier das ist
wieder ein etwas längerer command ich
hoffe ich schaffe es jetzt hier in der
zeit wo ich rede bis zum anfang zu
laufen wir sehen das schon dünner blabla
und hier am anfang zusammen giant
allerdings ist dieser zeit mit einem
schwer ausgestattet und wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise ich immer clique sie
schon da kommt ein riesiges schwer
wieso ich das grad angehört wie mickey
mouse wahrscheinlich gar nicht oder
jedenfalls ist es quasi einfach ein
unsichtbarer scheint also das seht ihr
auch wenn ich hier mal hin schlage
irgendwo hallo da da seht ist da kann
ich jetzt den giants schlagen bisher
irgendwie stimmt und das ist halt das
item von männerhand ich kann das jetzt
auch ersetzen ich könnte da ich bin mir
nicht so wow der befehls block steht
quasi genau im client drin die teilt
jetzt einfach aus als wird da oben
dieses schwert drinnen sein was in
dieser einen sage rausgezogen werden
muss ich weiß nicht was bei david gegen
goliath ich bin mir überhaupt nicht
sicher mit mit mythologie und zum ganzen
tag jedenfalls kann man dieses dieses
item am anfang hat auch ersetzen ich bin
mir allerdings nicht sicher ich habe
gerade glaube ich gar keinen richtigen
minecraft blog wir halt in echt heißt im
gedächtnis ich schreib einfach mal red
unterstrich wohl ich hoffe mal das geht
jetzt und zwar haben wir jetzt irgendwo
geht das nicht okay ich habe gerade
einfach nochmal inventar nachgeschaut
ich hab das ja immer so eingestellt dass
ich sehen kann wie die ganzen sachen
auch in minecraft heißt und zwar werde
ich jetzt einfach mal ihren unterstrich
oder hin packen das heißt wir müssten
letztendlich nachher eine riesige haben
wenn ich das ganze jetzt ein gebe ich
hoffe es klappt schäuble unterstrich hof
fertig wir drücken und wir haben ja
meine lieben freunde wir haben eine
riesige innenhof wird das ganze auch mal
aus damit ihr das ganze wirklich da
klatschen
hier zerstört jetzt gerade jedenfalls
kann man mit diesem command halt einfach
riesige item spawnen lassen das ganze
geht natürlich auch mit mittig mal ich
weiß nicht ob es jetzt mit red bull
gegangen ist oder so beispielsweise ob
es überhaupt rote wolle heisst in
minecraft das heißt es heißt einfach nur
wohl okay ist dann werde ich das ganze
jetzt auch noch mal zeigen dass das
ganze auch mit blöcken funktioniert das
stelle ich das hier einfach mal hin
pace zu den kommentar und scrollt zum
anfang ihr müsst hat quasi einfach
dieses anfangs altem verändern damit ein
anderes altern als als riesigen blog das
bauen könnte und zwar schreibe ich hier
jetzt einfach mal wohin so fertig drücke
hier und wir haben einen riesigen wolle
klotz einfach mal das ganze geht
natürlich auch mit tnt und nimm werfer
und ein crafting table und was weis ich
half sap steps was ich alles das war auf
jeden fall kommt nummer drei und freunde
da das kommt noch mal drei mal und ich
sehe schon wieder in der spur wir sind
bei 14 dann halt minuten nicht das ganze
natürlich wieder runter schneiden
allerdings ich weiß nicht das ganze
video geht dann vielleicht zu neun zehn
minuten oder so ich hoffe euch hat es
gefallen weil ich bin zurzeit echt ich
bin ehrlich mit euch freunde ich möchte
keine videos machen wenn ich keinen bock
hatte und die letzten vier tage da wurde
zwischendurch vier tage hat kann man
nichts kam war ich halt wirklich einfach
im urlaub und hatte keine videos macht
weil ich wirklich auch keinen bock hat
natürlich hätte ich im urlaub was
aufnehmen können irgend ein blog oder so
was hab ich hatte einfach keinen bock
nur als ich ja noch verrückt war und
einfach im zug saß vier stunden hab ich
mir über alles gedanken gemacht und habe
mir gesagt so was sollte man eigentlich
nur machen wenn man wirklich bock drauf
hat deswegen war ich jetzt auch so ein
bisschen dagegen dass ich mir da immer
diese tage festgelegt habe so von wegen
ja freitags kommen immer die komanis
dienstags ifex und so das ist halt so
wie wenn man so fußballtraining hat es
ist ja auch so da hat man halt die
festgeschriebenen tage in der woche du
hast dreimal viermal die woche training
dann musst du da hinkommen es kann
allerdings war sein dass du
dienstagstraining hast aber du hast
montags bericht die bock auf fußball
aber dienstags einmal gar nicht ist halt
einfach so das tägliche befinden
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht ja kommen
commands mache jetzt einfach dann wenn
ich bock habt das kann es sein dass eine
woche hochgenommen jetzt irgendwie mal
fünf mal die woche dreimal commands
vorgestellt werden oder sowas kann auch
mal sein dass im monat gar nichts kommt
das wird allerdings nicht der fall sein
weil mir diese serie echt viel spaß
macht sachen zu entdecken und vor allem
andere künstler sag ich mal zu supporten
die sich diese commands ausdenken hier
findet alle links und kommerz in der
beschreibung ich hoffe ihr stimmt damit
meiner meinung überein was eure meinung
zu dem thema werden und irgendwann
wieder unter ihr jetzt sogar bis zum
ende dran geblieben seid spiele ich euch
noch ein wundervolles lied von der
kollege sei der bereich freunde